il joue sur une oeuvre d'art réalisé par
georges mas yonath en 1976 c'est l'un
des fondateurs du mouvement fluxus un
courant artistique où l'humour et
l'autodérision se décline sur tous les
supports
enfin du nouveau ça c'est trop c'est
trop lent je trouve c'est sympa c'est
enfin du nouveau coca cola c'est pas
nouveau grand bain à s'affaisser mieux
déjà là donc j'aime bien ça me fait
sincère quand j'aime bien les
collections de la fondation du doute
interpelle avec près de 300 oeuvres et
documents dans lesquels les visiteurs
peuvent aussi se plonger on est dans un
espace qui concerne l'éphémérité c'est à
dire les sensations qui peuvent être
éphémère comme celle de se plonger dans
un bain de bauchi ou alors comme le
faisait de geoffrey hendrix à peindre
des nuages ya pas plus éphémère que
nuages et à dix on a beaucoup travaillé
sur les haricots aussi comme les idées
germent comme les haricots germe dans la
tête et voilà c'est un mélange comme ça
tout le temps autour de ça et en plus
c'est une oeuvre sonore
[Musique]
les artistes du fluxus aimait s'amuser
dollar joue et du hasard et de
l'accident il abordait aussi des thèmes
plus sérieux je minimalisme comment
faire avec peu c'est un sujet
aujourd'hui d'actualité ne pas dépenser
finalement
on a besoin de l'art pour se rendre
compte que la vie est encore plus
intéressante que tout et voilà c'est la
boucle est bouclée et c'est exactement
ce qu'on a voulu faire ici avec cette
idée d'un parcours où on est acteur ou
on est vivant on est on est libre on se
sent libre du vin coule pouvoir faire
des choses c'est rare dans un musée les
visiteurs peuvent déjà avoir un
avant-goût ludique de la grande fête qui
se profile à la rentrée pour fêter les
60 ans du mouvement fluxus